hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the chenai grand Masters
round four it is gukesh versus Alexandra
pret and before we check out this game
there are more news possible news from
the candidates tourament in 2024 just in
the previous video I announced that
lener Dominguez Perez and param makulu
are no longer in contention for a f
candidates tournament and we were down
to the final four but it seems a new
Challenger emerged ala fua will be
playing a tournament uh where he will
play six rated games and the uh average
rating of his opponent is 2500 and
something so in order to actually
qualify and overtake Wesley because he's
trailing by some four and a half points
Wesley is some maybe five rating points
higher rated than him alza will have to
win all six games probably five and a
half out of six will not be enough for
him he will have to take it six out of
six and he already played the first game
today uh and uh he won so he already
overtook laner and now uh it is only
Wesley that is stopping him from
qualifying in the cand its tournament I
still haven't seen the game I will
probably probably get it tomorrow and
then I will check it out but now let's
focus on this one uh also could be very
important for the FED candidates
tournament not via the rating spot but
via the Fay uh fed fiday circuit so
let's check it out it is gkes versus
Alexander PR yesterday PR lost to Arjun
it was it was a really brutal fighting
game but you know that when Alexander PR
plays that it's going to be it's going
to be a fun game to watch so let's check
out uh gkes has the white pieces and he
opens with Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to C5
PR goes for the Sicilian Defense Knight
if3 Knight to C6 and now Bishop to B5
the medino rosimo attack and pawn to E5
it looks like you can win a pawn here
but uh you've seen enough games that you
know that this is impossible because
after you capture Queen D4 just attacks
the Knight and the pawn uh but just to
be sure so castles and now there are a
couple many games that reach this
position top move here is Bishop to D6
later on you're going to put it to C7
and only then Advance the D Pawn some
other popular moves like Knight to gt7
pawn to D6 right away but here we have
Bishop to E7 and it is already now as of
move forward that we have a completely
new game so how does GES go about this
well just a normal uh development Rook
to E1 and now Knight to D4 again
seemingly breaking opening principles by
moving the same piece twice but okay who
are we who are we um judge such strong
players Knight captures and D4 C
captures and now Pawn to C3 challenging
the the pawn Center here Knight to F6
and now C captures on D4 we have e
captures and D3 so PR still stuck with
the Double D Pawn but it could also be
very strong if it uh puts pressure on
G's position let's say C3 and D3 squares
if you can hold on to those squares for
for the rest of the game should be very
nice uh we have castles Knight to D2 and
Now Pawn to D5 striking in the center
stopping Knight to C4 uh we have Pawn to
E5 advancing and now Knight to D7 we
have Knight F3 preparing to pick up the
pawn on D4 and queen to B6 defending and
attacking the bishop on B5 and here uh
you should play Pawn to A4 it seems like
the the the the cleanest way to tackle
this setup point being that if uh black
charges with A6 you will trade here
captures captures and you will play A5
and you will just very nicely control
the entire board but here gush went back
Bishop to A4 and now uh Alexander gets a
very nice position Knight to C5 okay
attacks the bishop Bishop C2 and now
Bishop to G4 and now Gish cannot take
the D4 Pawn uh unless he wants to play
something like H3 and G5 kick away the
bishop and then capture but this will
sort of weaken his King side and
interestingly that's exactly what it
does it's the candidate spot that is on
the line and he goes for it H3 Bishop to
H5 and pawn to G4 uh we have Bishop to
G6 and now uh Knight captures on D4 okay
he he grabs the pawn and he is now up a
clean Pawn uh we have Knight backed to
E6 offering a trade of knights and now
well you could go Knight to F5 and it
does look like a very nice move gukas
just goes back Knight to F3 Rook eight
to C8 and now Bishop to B3 the queen
can't really move anywhere as the bishop
will be poorly placed here so Bishop to
B3 and also now you can develop your
dark Square Bishop the queen will not be
attacking the B2 Pawn we have Queen to
B5 putting pressure on the D3 pawn and
gcas just advances it the D4 we have
Pawn to B Bishop to B4 attacking The
Rook here Rook to E3 and now Knight to
F4 and PR really has a lovely position
here the problem is it's already uh
close to losing but um uh neither of
them really picked up on this and even I
when I looked at what what the big deal
was with the engine I still don't get it
like the the engine says Knight H4 and
it's winning for white uh but you know
engines are uh weird creatures and the
point is that whatever black plays let's
say Rook F to d8 you will put a knight
to F5 and okay it looks nice I mean yeah
who who saying that it doesn't look nice
and now after black plays something you
will bring the Rook to F3 put pressure
on that Knight and once the Knight moves
you will put the Rook to G3 and the
engine says this is just
overwhelming uh but yeah of course we
are not engin so uh we have just Bishop
to D2 uh contesting the bishop on B4 uh
and now Knight captures an H3 also what
the uh engine move uh idea did is that
it defended the H3 Pawn by playing by
just moving the knight uh but here G
just says no take the pawn you can have
the pawn I'm going for the win here
Knight captures an H3 check King G2
Knight F4 check and King to G3 gush
attacking the Knight with the King uh
Knight back to E6 and now Pawn to a four
which also means that Gish will win the
D5 Pawn so Queen to A5 you cannot leave
the bishop here defenseless and now
Bishop captures on B4 Queen captures and
Bishop captures on D5 and this gives him
a pass D Pawn uh but also a very very
dangerous E Pawn and here uh you can't
really capture on B2 if you capture on
B2 then Rook to B3 is extremely annoying
you have to trade Queens here and once
the Queens get off the board uh Rook
captures some B7 you'll pick up the A7
Pawn you'll start advancing the past a
pawn uh Bishop already guards the
queening square this is uh very good for
white so instead Rook to C2 by Alexander
going after the B2 Pawn this way but now
gcas just pushes it to B3 and okay Rook
to d8 putting pressure on the bishop
also once the bishop moves you will go
after this um Pawn on D4 again my phone
starts listening to me and it even
narrates what I'm saying for some reason
uh Bishop to C4 and now Knight captures
on D4 so the D Pawn is gone but you
still have the very dangerous uh E Pawn
uh Knight captures on D4 we have Rook to
D2 now winning the piece back and now
Queen to E1 paralyzing The Rook here if
the Rook moves then the queen on B4
hangs uh so of course Rook eight
captures on D4 and now we have Pawn to
E6 right away by Gish uh a slightly more
precise move order uh would have been
Rook to A2 yeah just put more pressure
on The Rook here remember the Rook
cannot move and once the queen is
defended now you play E6 and now you
have some very nasty tactics here for
example if F captures you're going to
play Rook captures on D2 and after Queen
captures you will play Bishop captures
on E6 and now okay you can't really go
here due to Rook F3 check so you're
going to have to go to h8 but still Rook
F3 trying to sacrifice the queen for a
nice Checkmate on f8 uh so Pawn to H5
let's say making some room for the for
the king but now you will just sorry not
to that obviously you will TR you will
trade uh and now just G captures an H5
Bishop captures and Rook to to F5
winning uh a pawn once the bishop moves
doesn't really matter where you're going
to pick up a pawn the B3 Pawn is
defended uh you will also very quickly
pick up the the B7 pawn and it will be
winning uh but gash went for E6 right
away and now uh what do you play here
well uh the the most resilient way to
face this move is Rook captures on C4 uh
but it's still not a lot like Rook
captur C captures an F7 with check
Bishop captures now B captures rook and
now let's say you give a check King to
G2 and H6 giving some breeding room for
your king uh if you if you capture the
pawn then Rook d8 could be really
annoying and okay black continues to
fight but it's not it's not pretty H but
instead uh prka went for Queen to D6
check right away and now King to H3 and
now H there really aren't all that many
great moves F captures on E6 potentially
the the best defense But Here pawn to H5
was played sort of giving the black king
some breeding room on H7 and also
preparing to go after the white king uh
but the position uh could not be more
winning for gash so feel free to pause
the video and uh find the winning idea
while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
figuring out that the pawn is
Unstoppable and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Pon E7
yeah you even have uh I didn't enable
the clock times for this one but uh prka
was uh down to some 2 minutes and 50
second no down to 1 minute and 50
seconds when he made his last move so he
still had some time to figure out that
he shouldn't allow E7 but obviously any
move isn't spectacular so Pawn to E7 was
played and now the problem is you don't
have a way to go after the white king if
you play H Capt on G4 check uh King will
move now Queen to C6 with check King to
G1 there's no continuation and uh E8 is
Unstoppable you can't even play F6 due
to the uh due to the pin here so instead
after E7 he said all right it's now or
never he played Rook captures on G4 now
E8 Queen gcash gets another queen
intergame king to H7 and now just Bishop
captures on F7 and what do you play here
uh if you trade I mean a white is up a
queen you can't really trade so here he
tried Queen to F6 it's a it's a neat
trick if Gish actually captures The Rook
he will deliver Checkmate on H4 but of
course Gish you will not qualify for the
candidates tournament by playing such
moves he played Bishop captur on G6 with
check and that's uh pretty much it King
to H6 was played uh if you capture I
mean doesn't really do all that much
King to H6 was played now Queen to h8
with check King captures and now finally
Rook to E6 winning the black queen
stopping Checkmate uh and okay few more
moves were made Rook to H4 check King to
G2 even Rook captures uh Rook to G4
check now you have to go to the file
otherwise black will have a Perpetual so
King to F1 and now he frees up his Queen
Rook captures on F2 with check Queen
captures and queen captures on E6 uh but
it doesn't matter uh Gish is still up a
full Queen so Rook to E1 goes after the
black queen queen to A6 with check but
now uh Rook to E2 and he was in this
position on move uh uh 44 that Alexander
prka resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here like you
almost have a Perpetual but not really
if you play something like Queen to D3
prepare Queen to D1 check okay you have
the Rook controlling the G file uh it's
merely a matter of a couple of checks
like Queen E8 check and now if okay you
go here then Queen captures an H5 so you
go to H6 but then Queen eat to E3 with
check forces a queen trade and that's
pretty much it uh you're up a queen now
and you will very quickly Checkmate the
black king so yeah after Rook D2 prka
resigned and a nice victory for for Gish
which ties him with pentala har Krishna
for first place and remember we said
that Arjun needs to win clear first in
order to qualify for the candidates
tournament via the FIA circuit uh but
for gkes it is enough to win shared
first and he will also qualify for the
candidates tournament so he has much
better chances and like I said he's
currently tied with Hari Krishna on Two
and a Half out out of four so we'll see
we we'll see what happens still many
things are possible and we'll see what
alza does he already won one game what
he does with with with the other five uh
will be interesting but fiday also had
something to say about this I don't want
to trick you guys so I'm just going to
read to you what fiday said uh let me
just uh load it
up
yeah uh so seems that they are they are
onto it and they say today on December
18th the mini matches featuring grandmas
ala fuja began in chart in France uh his
hometown the sixth game tournament
pits ala fuja against three veteran
players with an average rating of
2497 so some are below 2500 some are
above 2500 and concerns have Arisen
regarding the tournament's potential
purpose whether it was orchestrated to
Aid Mr fua uh in boosting his rating for
potential qualification into the
candidates tournament 2024 now the
international Chess Federation would
like to point out that according to
Clause 0.4 of its rating regulations
fiday reserves the right not to rate a
specific tournament so they will
obviously look into the tournament look
into how it's organized look into the
games and if they you know find that
something fishy has been happening here
then of course they will not rate the
tournament uh F has already sent an
official request that the organizers of
the event we will carefully follow and
investigate all aspects of the
organization of the above mentioned
tournament and all the games played by
its participants before deciding whether
to rate it the international Chess
Federation is dedicated to addressing
not just this specific case but also
similar occurrences that may arise
discussions will be held to explore
potential amendments to the fiday rating
regulations uh aiming to prevent such
situations in the future fiday
reiterates its unwavering commitment to
upholding fair play and ensuring equal
opportunities for all chess players so
there we have it h so you know things
are happening Fay you know the the great
watchful eye of fiday of course sees
everything and we'll you know we'll see
what tomorrow brings but yeah some of
you are comparing this to yeah but how
how did they allow ding Len to play all
of those games to qualify for the
candidates tournament well ding never
actually needed rating ding just didn't
play any games and you have to play a
certain amount of games in a uh in a in
a calendar year to be able to qualify
for the tournament so it doesn't matter
if he won them or if he lost all of them
he would still qualify uh okay maybe not
if he lost all of them but uh I mean
he's ding he's not going to Lo lose
games uh so it's not really really the
same and they were all incredibly
fighting games we've seen how he played
I mean they were just brutal games uh
hard to calculate like not any uh you
know opening stuff and then they you
know maybe someone overlooked something
that they were really hard games to play
uh so it's not really really the same
thing uh but yeah we'll see what happens
uh you know every day we have a new
Contender trying trying out for the
candidates tournament so we'll see what
tomorrow brings uh so that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it and a little
bit of extra info about the cand this
tournament seems like every day we'll
have new information so stay tuned I
would like to thank an anonymous person
Benjamin hurger El on a shelf Gregory
Novak and kenth F for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens uh
in the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day